today I'm Batman I'm Batman we actually
talk about Batman and there's gonna be
novel today
right here on fat man a Batman
well the Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith
I'm mark Renard and how are you mark I'm
doing well sir how's you new years it's
like we like we didn't see each other we
waited we sat in silence over time until
finally the camera a method like how are
you don't talk to me it's like I'm
getting in character I need it quiet in
order to play mark barnard I can't [ __ ]
around I can't like be all jolly about
it just pretty we're here dude 2017 yes
we made it the end of days it's begun
but you know what [ __ ] all that we're
here to fiddle as Rome burns man we're
here to talk about things that make
living worthwhile [ __ ] everything else
Batman and in that spirit of that they
just announced
well they announced a little while ago
back in November I think you know
directing an episode of the insanely
funny ABC that come the gold lucky so
I'm going to drag an episode they just
announced today what that episode is
about tell me the Goldbergs for those
that may not watch the show set in the
80s and they go across the 80s they're
never very specific or it's not
chronological I just know it's not like
now we're doing 84 that ping-pong all
around and so they'll say like the year
was 1982 something you know fast and
loose with it but our episode or the
episode I get to direct is about the
opening of Batman Michael Keaton's
Batman it's so they called you clearly
I'm Matt Meyer who I do talk salad and
scream legs podcast with which yes it
still exists people like you start you
have none in here still [ __ ] together
he works on the show he's like you on
direct an episode that was like yeah and
so we didn't know what it was gonna be
turns out it's this now that makes sense
couldn't be more perfect now I'm telling
you like like it's so far like with
directing a flash or two flashes and a
Supergirl which airs in two weeks for
three weeks on CW January 23rd I think
when everything comes back and now
Goldberg's that's about bat
I'm just getting lucky man it's like
they're just pitching him their
underhand pitching at this point what
would you like to hit oh man thank
[ __ ] god I sat down talked out and go
over a wonderful [ __ ] dude who's got
like an office to die for with like
trinkets ball sort very very much one of
us hmm
but the episode the script is wonderful
I want to give the the dude credit I
don't know everybody's name you know
because I just started working there but
the script is a [ __ ] hysterical and
like you know when you're a writer when
you try to write comedy for a living you
know you can definitely read something
and be like that's very humorous or
that's funny I can see as that's gonna
play well without like laughing no but
they were like four times during the
script where I like literally laughed
out loud and I'm not saying I'm a tough
[ __ ] guard up please but you know
it's much harder make somebody laugh if
they're like well I'm in the business of
funny and [ __ ] and it there are four or
five moments where I [ __ ] literally
lol as they say Andrew Secunda that's
who wrote my script episode 417 s called
the dynamic duo nice pops just give you
a preview pops played by George Segal he
is a Adam West's Batman guy and of
course young Adam and and Barry R
Michael Keaton nice man I sense I sense
a rift in the force yes a little bit but
oh my god this show like [ __ ] it I'm
like knowledge I laugh a lot four or
five times
no [ __ ] and if everyone's gonna be
like your stone your crowd everything
I'm gonna [ __ ] cry buried in this
episode it's really [ __ ] beautiful
they do a nice thing over there where
they [ __ ] like do legit funny legit
funny like [ __ ] [ __ ] and then they
like wrap it up with like give me your
heart like dirty Wonder Years what a con
is like it's so it's so it's a wonderful
show all the [ __ ] in it are so
[ __ ] funny talented and it [ __ ]
behind the camera just this talented
dude that's great the script is [ __ ]
dynamite and again like I'm gonna get
credit people go
directed to find episode I'm watching
like I met everybody and like we toured
and stuff like that the sets and we
location scout these folks know exactly
what they're doing
it's not like I'm bringing a vision like
I'm getting paid to watch him make the
Goldberg so I'm gonna take that money
and put my name on the show it's gonna
be amazing a seat in the house oh my god
[ __ ] like everything else why did I
try so hard
TV so that's happening man I'm shooting
it we start on Monday and so I don't
know when it airs in a couple months I
guess like I guess we're not that far
behind but believe me I'll [ __ ] let
you know what it's about to air
Supergirl is about to air my Supergirl
January 23rd but on the subject of
Batman yes tell me do that script is
good like it's really touching really
funny and then really touching and you
know that's like it couldn't be more in
my [ __ ] sweet spot well I mean that
that's the things on my stick I can only
choke a dick on this one joke on a dick
I mean that I mean we've talked about
our experiences as youths going to see
Batman and to use the two youths and
like everybody's story around that movie
usually takes place when they're in high
school kind of cresting into adulthood
and those stories have this poignancy to
them they have this there's this nugget
of like I'm just becoming a man ditching
people to go see Batman and some
midnight show it's a mall somewhere
there's the Dare Punk hangs a tale and
that tail cannot go tell them that's
excellent
beautifully put try and get a job in
this [ __ ] show hi there you go
there's a writer it's very happy about
that
Vanessa no guy deep cuts us and no guys
he'll he's [ __ ] hysterical like he's
really good on son of zorn have you been
watching this uh no it's it's hidden
miss like the concept is is kind of
interesting but you know it's a Guinea
sitcom has its highs and it's lows but
but he's always really strong he's the
player to be named later
ladies man he's a bull durham of Sno you
know what I'm saying like some of his he
broke his records off the show so to
speak but he was like the Phil Hartman
of that show for a while or the who's
the kid now he's going on for like 50
years
Kenan Kenan Thompson Tim was there for
like yeah like 10 years yeah by adding
like through the Hartman's and the the
Farley's and all of that stuff there's
Lou the glue there's the the ladies man
all right so that that's gonna be a
blast
let's talk about Batman another new
actual Batman in other news now they're
making this Justice League picture which
we're all [ __ ] excited about correct
they announced a couple years back hey
y'all like the guy that made our go
right he's gonna make a [ __ ] Batman
movie and the world went apeshit yeah
remember thought just the [ __ ]
thought of a Ben Affleck the guy who
made the town is gonna make Batman hmm
who's dick - I gotta suck to make it
happen they were like it's happening you
don't have to do that at all just give
us your money when it's yeah I remember
at Comic Con last year they announced
like here are the directors of our DC
Universe and we're patty Jenkins I
brought out Rick from Wahiawa who is now
not a director in the DC Universe on the
flash they brought out and they brought
I've been and they brought out Zack and
they're like here are our directors he's
doing a Batman movie standalone Batman
movie written with Jeff Jones called the
Batman which you know had you were the
chosen one and I like all of it just
seemed like it would bring balance to
the force
recently I guess he gave an interview
yeah he did interview for the LA Times
and how do you know this Marc you read
the LA time I ever --day cuz I was a
film editor for the LA Times man give
him a single give me a single say that
again
film editor for the LA time back to the
2-shot legit legit right so what
happened so yeah Josh Rotenberg one of
our writers spent like an afternoon with
been talking about his new movie lived
by night talking about Justice League
talking buddy it was a year in Affleck
and
he's had a year and so he mentioned we
talked about the Batman and he said well
you know I'm I will direct it if the
script is right but if the script is not
right I'm not gonna shoot this movie
hold the [ __ ] phone give him a single
script a right we don't fight back to to
chef paraphrasing better as a soundbite
I was Don King that a little bit so wait
is like really so now there's there's a
whiff of I mean I there's been for about
a year or whiff of like well the scripts
not right yeah it's so it's a gonna
happen smile gonna happen maybe gonna
happen but I got a date they got a day
2018 I believe they've announced their
release dates that means they need to be
shooting Oh Wednesday yeah pretty much
I mean to their credit though like I
would rather them not make a movie then
rush into making a shitty one duh and I
don't think they're gonna do that I
think they've already taken a few
[ __ ] hits over BBS which was not a
shitty movie but like you know like
people are like where's your marvel and
then Suicide Squad they made a bunch of
loot but more like stale where's your
marvel so you know looking like Justice
League and Wonder Woman gonna deliver a
kind of well more well-balanced comic
book movie like everybody seems to be
looking for right out of these DC movies
but the Batman was gonna be like you
can't yeah are you kidding me the
[ __ ] made the 10 I'm gonna say
it again the town or go I'm gonna go
even further back Gone Baby Gone which
is the amazing [ __ ] movie that guy is
gonna make the Batman with Deathstroke
as the bad guy how's the only part that
I was kind of like you know not by that
yeah I mean I like the clip they put
online and like he look badass but it's
just like I don't know like well it's
very much there's a bigger there's a
well of you love of villains that you
know there are but in these sort of Iron
Man mold of I have to fight myself all
the time
it's the me another dude in armor find
me another rich guy who's got money to
spend on his
mad quest for whatever then it's fine an
eyepatch and it also gives you a chance
to let Batman sword fight some movies
alright see doing your job where you
want a brother my worthless [ __ ] so
that movie yeah the big question is
where is this [ __ ] movie and now the
answer is he's he's saying maybe yeah I
won't
yeah it's like give the script a right
and again he's writing it with Jeff
Jones I'm sure at some point so the
interview Josh Rutenberg so did Josh
turnaround be like will make it right no
you're right into the right boy right
right right right he did he's got the
skills behind the keys I hope the [ __ ]
he does it are you kidding me man like
could you imagine you take that kind of
talent the talent that gave us I'm gonna
say it again give me a single our go
back to the Argo [ __ ] yourself Argo [ __ ]
yourself
the this picture it's fine motion
picture imagine that melt filmmaker
mmm-hmm milf maker that filmmaker is
making back the Batman yeah but I think
you know he did get kind of beaten up
because of Batman V Superman like that's
well that's what I'm thinking man like
in a world I don't mean look I don't
this is I say this with [ __ ] let's
make this clear give me a single I
haven't spoken to Ben Affleck in
probably three years so I got no inside
dope on this back to the 2-shot this is
not coming alike at his buddy I'm we
like I mean brothers waiting partners
where your friends like 48 hours yeah I
think he regardless I'm saying we're
riding I think I'm just saying like I
ain't talked to this dude in [ __ ]
years so I'm just spitting it's my mom
I'd be Bruce Wayne or Ben Affleck Brady
here's my if I had to guess maybe it's
like to like
everyone George Lucas made the prequels
mmm after [ __ ] decades of everybody
being like sky made of movies and
[ __ ] stores make more Star Wars and
they did they were like stop it you're
the worst at this he gave an interview I
think it was the New York Times movie
you know they were like you gonna do it
again he's like why bother
yeah buddy yells at you and tells you're
doing it wrong you step up you see the
expectation right here single camera
again
the maker of our go back to the two-shot
there's a level of expectation for that
mm-hmm that that movie about Batman has
to be the greatest movie about that
Minute Maid if it's me do I want that
kind of pressure in my life I mean if
you're making a Batman movie have to
make it fearless you have to just dive
in and [ __ ] do it you also have to
have something to lose
yeah and or no nothing nothing that's it
my bad the opposite of something yes you
gotta have nothing to lose
yeah and you've got to lose so like if
Mike you late in terms of people are you
know are don't you and live my nights
come down and stuff like he's considered
a very serious filmmaker so even if he
makes like a film that cineast you like
oh my god this is this reinvents Batman
if it doesn't please the fans like
you'll take him down they'll take the
whole movie down like I feel like if he
made if it was Man Bat Man of Steel then
the Batman yeah
so Ben gets to make his like unn unn
tinged by reality I'm beaten by the
winds of fan disdain then that's oh
that's a brave filmmaker that's a dude
who's got nothing to lose that's a news
I want to make my movie make my [ __ ]
movie after BBS after the sound of
silence when seemed to be no contact but
he seemed to be affected by yeah he's
all gunshots and you know I get it like
it seemed like and I think he gave an
interview where he was just like like I
thought exactly so I don't know maybe
like right and maybe he's like I was
down black is white I can't you know why
enter into that tender trap right I hope
not because you got Geoff Johns you got
talent behind single agro extra two shot
that's it you've got a movie I'm gonna
[ __ ] if it's the greatest Batman movie
or not you got a movie right there right
do it do do it just like shine the yeah
man that's a missed opportunity I hope
he doesn't I hope that's not yeah or
like I hope they crack it but at the
same time also like some people be like
oh you know you're right
if you don't want to make it I'm not
[ __ ] pressuring them but like I hope
if he walks away from it it's for the
right reasons and if the right reason is
I can't get the script right then that's
fine - that's fair I would much rather
like we said have not a bad Batman movie
then a bad Batman but I would because
we've survived bad Batman movies we have
but I could I mean I would be perfectly
happy if they took Batman and Robin away
take my mother's misery I hope he
doesn't man and I you know not the least
of which because I'm a selfish little
[ __ ] Batman [ __ ] and so I want as
much as possible all over me
and but that would mean if he doesn't
start this year then they're not gonna
hit that 2018 day now so today at that
point go hey we need a Batman movie so
we're gonna make one you can make the
next one or or it's like then you slide
in Gotham City sirens so that's when you
slot in like cyborg a little bit earlier
like they've got enough pieces cuz I got
a slot something in to fill the flash
slot which is now vacant still do they -
no they did Howard the Millers you're
sitting there going like I'm waiting
around everything
I'm dining yeah yeah that's right they
don't have a cyborg director I don't
think or do they did I miss them having
a cyborg director I don't think so like
it's the back half of that castle I'm
sailing
we [ __ ] know why are we speculating
but isn't that what they do in fantasy
sports isn't that what fans - yeah this
is like fantasy studio [ __ ] running
[ __ ] yeah if I owned the Warner Brothers
and I had these pieces here's how I
start the day of the game and they don't
seem to be starting anybody today they
gave I like it that would make me play
fantasy football football do you
remember that thing it was in the the
mid-90s I think the Hollywood stock in
yeah BH sxx yeah where you just had a
building I'm [ __ ] like Santa Monica
Boulevard they make money I don't I
don't know I don't know I didn't
understand their model I was always sad
that our [ __ ] stock wasn't more it
would be high like when they announced a
movie Jay and Silent Bob strike back
with oh yeah well you would think would
a supposed to have been some kind of
predictive model for how things will do
with the audience but it never did
because just literally what the stock
market is it was just bet on futures
totally it was just like a thousand guys
like us doing it not the world at large
so you couldn't pull any real data off
of it it was just outed by Terminator 2
okay and for a while they would report
about it to like you and then their
Hollywood Stock Exchange
what's makers on the rise kind of crazy
oh what a good old [ __ ] late 90s on
ya the tech boom no what about then it
came back except for that that never
came back nope some [ __ ] just does not
come back mmm that's the lesson here
today terrible segue of course we lost
Carrie Fisher mark and I've spoken about
it on SModcast and on Hollywood
babble-on podcast and stuff obviously
big deal you know for all of us who grew
up watching those movies HBO has that
documentary bright lights yeah they've
moved up we're supposed to like Saturday
December January has happened in this
weekend it was supposed to be happening
in the spring but in light of both Kari
and her mom
they moved it up to now the trailer is
up online I mean he'd been playing
festivals like it had been done to go to
cannard I forget where what's a can and
just played the Palm Springs Film
Festival in the desert there was there
had been talk that that Kerry was going
to go to New York and work on it a
little bit more like maybe add another
chapter to it but I don't think that
ever happened so it's if you pop on
YouTube now you see the trailer it's
[ __ ] wonderful but it airs like
[ __ ] at the end of the trailer you can
watch the whole damn thing if you got
HBO apparently this by the time you see
this you can see that so you want to
honor your princess and you do that's a
fine way to do it this weekend trailers
like wonderful instantly makes you go
like I wish Debbie Reynolds was my mom
they make the mom and daughter dynamic
they make him like I'm a dude so I wish
I was my mom's daughter like it makes it
look very appealing and stuff and
there's lots of young footage of Carrie
yeah like that's crazy I was watching
the trailer and they've got like pre
Star Wars footage of Carrie I mean when
we were putting together in our tributes
and stuff for the paper like we had been
covering her since she was a fetus like
it was Debbie Reynolds pregnant with the
first child
like Debbie Reynolds Eddie Fisher like
split up and there's like four year old
Carrie in the corner like just she had
been famous since before she was born
that's nuts yeah and like all of that
stuff is out there all of that footage
all of that like archival photography
it's just then it's beautiful stuff and
she was in shampoo right yeah those are
stars yeah so you can see young young
that place 15 16 years old yeah wow
you're right man I hadn't thought about
that she'd been covered since before she
was uncovered yeah for the first time
yeah big loss and it's still top the
news over a week later yeah I wrote one
a third time like after she had passed
so good and then just there like that
last scene has a totally different like
you vibe differently than you hope and
then it's oh Jesus hope yeah I I
probably I watched it again at home on
my Oscar screener hmm and the you know
maybe the first time I saw it be like
wow you know her teeth don't look as
real like maybe they shouldn't have
shown her face bah blah blah then after
watch watching it after Carrie passed it
feels like it certainly wasn't intended
to be such but it's almost a very sweet
no more mmm
watching those movies back to back was a
real trip particularly like right after
hearing about her passing like that's
mine my wife is never gonna watch robe 1
and that's how I got her watch rogue one
she loved it she was like now let's
watch Star Wars I was like who are you
weird a few people wow this is amazing
so we watched them back-to-back and it's
weird like when you think about like I
saw somebody's whole career I was a big
fan of her work I've talked about in
many places and and I knew her as well a
little bit in the real world but weird
to think that I saw her old career yeah
you know and like and not just the one
career in movies but the script
doctoring career the book writing career
the raconteur career I think we didn't
really see was that she have a direct I
believe she did I don't believe she did
I wonder why not so weird she grew up on
set so you know she probably had a knife
or she dragged her life she made a
masterpiece and sadly now she's gone so
but to honor so to honor her her up up
up um go watch bright lights is the
documentary on HBO this weekend it
really looks like worth your time it
looks like the kind of thing at the end
of which you gurgling mom like why
didn't we have the relationship yeah /
I'm kind of glad we didn't have that
relationship why were your dad rich
favors yeah it looks pretty fabulous oh
that's a great way to keep her you know
look you can't stop people from dying
it's the natural way of life
unfortunately they try and they can't
figure out how to stop this dying stuff
from happening the way to keep them
alive you know like in those movies what
not like how qui-gon
can come back you know as a force ghost
and how Ben Kenobi could go back as a
force ghost in our war we don't have
force ghosts in this world as far as I
know but what we do have is chitchat and
to keep it a memory alive so you talk
about person and they're gone but you
know it's like they're there for that
minute or two you keep that memory alive
that's the force that bond just flows
through us whatever and for some we
still have their lovely Holograms to
tell us that they're our only hope over
and over again general Kenobi my father
so Ben Kenobi worked for Bail Organa
well I think the like served it's like
is that what he said served he's a
sinner I'm a general [ __ ] serve
silicon Jedi serve nobody but myself and
the Jedi I brought him a kid one time
yes serving one time at the service not
two kids one kid you know what glad he's
gone scandalous to say when I'm on a
desert planet [ __ ] I was a servant
into work you gotta come and find me any
[ __ ] time you wanted to bring me
something cool to drink on this [ __ ]
desert hellhole and you might want to
lose the Kermit often I like the big of
Star Wars is like something he didn't
really try to make intentionally cut out
all the [ __ ] that he really likes long
kind of like the straight story thanks
for hanging out with seiran's that's how
you keep people alive laughs indeed joy
it's gonna be great 2017 don't be scared
no in the face of fear make something
create something you know if you don't
fear is something Bad's gonna happen
things will and fear fears change you
know it's just like there's trepidation
about things happening differently and
stuff
don't fear change embrace change by
creating change yourself make change I'm
not saying go out and change the world
I'm saying make some [ __ ] make peace art
make a podcast like us make a youtube
show make someone pregnant but ask him
first make money please ask them make
sure you ask him make love make a lot of
things just make this year that'll
that'll make you feel better
trust me creating [ __ ] makes everything
just a little bit better don't give a
[ __ ] what it is you make a piece of
pottery and some [ __ ] comes behind you
rubs your titties like an ghost what's
happen to me just recently the one your
titty rubbin mug and it was like people
would not stop talking about it that was
one of the movies a plate free you would
think it was gonna like Star Wars
it would just live forever and now I
wouldn't talks about ghosts anymore you
know they should it's a good movie good
[ __ ] flick go back and watch it was
his name Joe who wrote it Joe Don Baker
yeah wonderful [ __ ] script yeah he
also wrote Jacob's Ladder whoo he had a
good baby run there yeah you ain't
kiddin and he also did a movie the
Michael Keaton movie my life which is
like so sad he's not already videotapes
himself because he's got the cancer as
he's too um like dumps I'll start crying
I saw that with my father
Oh and he didn't have cancer he wasn't I
or anything but like it's a movie about
mortality that I watched with my
father at that point was in his like
late 50s or something like that oh what
an emotional [ __ ] train ride that
move him into Cole Kidman yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] it's a touching [ __ ] movie but
yeah make it a Bruce Joel room and
threesome recently man you watch
yourself a little ghost Jacob's Ladder
in my life I think he did something else
we're forgetting to you you might have
but I can for the life remember what I
want that's the way alabaster was seven
or eight years ago but yeah ghosts is
what really cut - he's alive just dead
inside decomposed saved nine years I
think he I think he did that
I think since great movies though yeah
I'm good dude alright there it is man
that's some bunch of recommendations men
need to do it one the intention but
that's very well we got there all right
man that's it for this week I'm fat man
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard
come back next episode same that time
same fat channel smart gets calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you